- Wait, it's finally summer, so like
- [Sam] Yeah.
- in Scotland, do you do like
big summer vacations there?
I love Scotland by the way.
- Yeah, I love Scotland.
Yeah, and we, as a child, we
used to go on summer vacations
to the beach, but it's not like
you guys here in California,
you know,
- It's like cold.
- it's raining, it's miserable.
You get in the, your mom
makes you get in the water,
you're freezing cold.
The first thing you wanna do is get out,
and get in the car.
But of course, you know, then you,
- Why does she make you get in?
- I know, like it's
supposed to be fun, right?
- Yeah, okay frolic.
- Yeah, so it's now nice
to come to the U.S.,
and actually have a proper beach vacation.
- It can be cold here, too.
I took my kids to the
beach the other day ,
and it was maybe not
comparatively speaking,
but they were like, get in.
And I was like a no, hard pass.
I was like, it's really cold.
Do you surf at all?
Or do anything like that?
- I have done a little in the U.S.,
and actually recently on
my show that I created
"Men In Kilts".
- Yeah. I love that.
(audience cheering)
- We uh,
- We had you on here about that, yeah.
- We did a little surfing in Scotland,
which is amazing,
because people don't
really think of surfing
in Scotland, right?
And actually it's amazing.
You get to the beach,
there's no one there.
So you get the whole thing to yourself.
- Cause it's cold.
Yeah, yeah.
- I'm not really selling
Scotland here, am I?
- No, I love Scotland, but I love rain.
So it rains a lot there, I love that.
- It does.
I think we've got about 20 different words
for rain and stuff.
- I know. Are they curse words?
- They are pretty much bad.
- You're like over it.
I love rain.
I grew up in Texas, so I love rain.
But have you been able to
explore like more than just LA,
like in the U.S.?
- I've been all over, yeah.
- Oh yeah?
- I mean actually when
I first came to America,
I traveled all around the U.S. by bus.
- Oh!
- And one of the experiences I had
is I actually went to Texas and
- Really?
- Yes, yeah.
- We're nice.
- Yeah, I remember nothing.
- Yeah. Oh, well.
- I met some very friendly,
- Went to some bars.
- Yeah. I went to this bar
but it was like underground in a ranch.
- Sure.
- And for, I just, I fell asleep and
- In Texas, you gotta be careful
who you're going underground with.
- Right? Yeah.
- Yeah.
- They were very friendly people,
I have to admit.
- Yeah. We are friendly.
We are friendly.
- Yeah.
- But is there anything about America,
that's still weird to you?
Like we drive on the
other side, obviously.
- Yeah, you do drive on the other side.
Actually, I love that.
I learned to drive at a very late age,
and have probably driven more in the U.S.,
than I have in the UK.
So, it kind of feels right
to be on the right hand side of the road.
But you guys have the four
way stop thing that's,
yeah, no, I love a roundabout.
- Oh, I like a roundabout.
- Yeah, right? There's
- Yep, yep.
Yep. Oh, I get what
you're saying, I guess.
Yeah. You only need two stops really,
and then the other can wait, I guess.
- Right. I don't know, I just
you always have to wait
for the person on the four-way stop,
and that confuses me.
- In Texas it's hard too,
'cause everyone's polite.
So it's like, no you go, no you go,
and you're there forever.
- Yeah. You get nowhere, right?
- Yeah, yeah.